it's always been difficult for roxanna
and her family to eke out a living
but the pandemic has made their lives
harder still
for her not working is not an option
it's for my family my mom and dad have
been
sick and the medicines are very
expensive
all we can do is go out and keep working
voting in bolivia is obligatory but
roxanna will go to the ballot box with
little optimism
even though the elections bring new
authorities the politics are always the
same
they campaign they talk a lot but when
they're in power they forget
i believe it will always be like that
olivia is striving for stability after
years of political turmoil which saw
former president eva morales flee the
country in 2019
to be replaced by a right-wing interim
government
socialists are now back in charge
nationally but it's the authority's
handling of the pandemic
that now underlines every campaign
promise every political decision
all the candidates all over the country
have said they'll fight against the
disease
but there are still particular problems
in each region in relation to
infrastructure
the pandemic has starkly highlighted the
issues that most concern bolivian voters
[Music]
the most important is health not just
physical but mental health
too and with what we're going through
right now with this virus
we also need to be economically stable
medical professionals are on strike over
government emergency measures to fight
the disease
while the number of daily new infections
continue to rise
covered 19 has killed more than 3 000
people in bolivia
luizar say a former minister in evil
morales government
won presidential elections last october
organized at the height of the pandemic
his first few months in office dominated
by copied 19.
the vaccines are arriving but not as
many and not as often as people would
like
es it is very difficult to buy vaccines
in the world
today is very difficult to get them all
countries are trying to buy vaccines
that's not what roxanna and millions of
bolivians like her want to hear
the degree of patience and understanding
they have in their politicians handling
of the pandemic
will be reflected in the ballot box
daniel schweinser juan osiris